こんにちは。この動画のテーマは、AIとは何か俯瞰する?です。
生成AIをですね、倫理的に、そして適切に使うために、それが一体何をしている技術なのかということを、ざっくりとでもですね、理解しておくと良いと思います。
ただ、その生成AIの仕組みに入る前にですね、まずはAIとはどんな技術かということをざっくりと俯瞰できればと思います。
まず、この入れ子の関係のこの図を見てみてください。
生成AIというとですね、なんかいかにも強そうで全部を包含してそうですが、そうではなくて、AI分野のごく一部なんですね。
スリーデータサイエンスのようなデータを扱う数学統計の分野の中に、AI、人工知能と呼ばれるものがあります。
この定義は、人が知的だと感じる処理を実現するシステムというふうに言われています。
その中に機械学習というようなデータを与えて、そこからパターンをですね、学んでいくAIというものがあります。
さらにその中に、ニューダルネットワークと呼ばれる多層のですね、パラメータの集まりによって、学習を進めていくAIというものがあります。
その技術の行くついた先にあるのが、生成AIなわけです。
生成AIは、文章や画像などを作ることができます。
言語系の生成AIであるトランスフォーマーの話であったり、画像などは、例えば拡散モデルなど、いくつもの種類があったりします。
生成AIというのは、あくまでAI技術のごく一部でしかありません。
皆さんが使っているYouTubeだろうかと、その他のですね、様々なソフトウェアだろうとですね、このAIというのはすでにアルゴリズムの中に含まれているんです。
AIはすでに環境になりました。
こうしたですね、中身を理解していく中にですね、情報とは何かということを簡単に説明させてください。
情報とは、4つの段階に分けたうちの、ここだというような定義をされることがあります。
情報のDIKWモデルというもので、これちょうど高校の教科書から実は取ってきているんですけども、皆さんほとんど覚えている人はいないかなと思います。
データ、例えばですね、客観的な事実と整理されていない状態のものから、何らかの基準で整理し分析し、人が解釈できるようにした状態としてインフォメーションがあります。
そこから知識をまとめて体系化し構造化した状態に慣れ違いあり、そこからですね、さらに価値観とかもらうとかですね、もっと深く、さまざまなところに応用可能なところまでですね、展開したのが知恵というものでございます。
研究とはですね、このデータのさまざまなレベル感を行ったり来たりする作業なんですけども、
その、この次元がですね、複数あるわけですが、
そのさまざまなところに今、AIが関わるようになってきています。
先ほど、AIの定義について、人が知的だと考える処理を実現するシステムだというふうにご説明を差し上げました。
アーティフィシャルインテリジェンスということもですね、言葉の通り、アーティフィシャルだし、インテリジェンスだしということなんですけども、
この言葉自体は実は案外古くて、1956年にアメリカのダートマス会議、
ダートマス大学で行われた会議によって名付けられました。
あと、皆さんですね、よくロボット、つまりドラえもんみたいなものをAIなんじゃないかと思うかもしれませんが、
それは違うんですね。AIというのはあくまで、そのような処理をするシステムのことであって、
ロボットは実体でございます。その2つは考えるのを分けておきましょう。
AIの中にはですね、ルールベース、人がルールを決めたり、あるいは知識を記入しているものがございます。
これはですね、問題が分けきれるもの、if分で定義できるものにはむちゃくちゃ強いわけでございます。
この状況の時にはこうというのが、きれいにルールとして書けるわけですから。
一方で、昨今のAI、生成AIをはじめとして、そうした内容はですね、機械学習であったり、
真相学習であったりするわけですが、それはですね、データを自ら学ぶということになっています。
その学び方というのは、ある意味ブラックボックス的で、どうしてそうなるのかというのを解釈するのはかなり難しくなっているんですね。
真相学習がですね、大きく羽ばたいた時に、Googleさんの猫を見分けるというAIがありました。
猫か犬かというのをですね、特に言っていないにもかかわらず、ウェブ上にある大量の画像データから、
こいつが猫なんだと認識したという話なんですけども、
その猫を見分けるというのをですね、完璧に書くのはかなり難しいんですね。
一方で、人間は、これは猫だなというのは一発でわかるわけです。
そこにルールと、実際の現実との差があるわけなんですけども、
なので、大量にですね、猫の画像を見せることによって、
学ばせるような、そういうふうな考え方というのが、機械学習の中で出てくるわけでございます。
機械学習の中には、大きく3つのものがあります。
1つ目はですね、教師ある学習で、正解を標識データで学ぶものでございます。
この画像は猫というのをですね、判断するようなものでございます。
まず最初に猫か犬か大量に勉強した後にですね、
新しい画像を見せて、これは猫だねというふうに出てくる、そういったものですね。
あと、教師の歴史学習というのもあります。
これは次元作品とクラスリングとかなんですけども、
似たもの同士をまとめるというものがあったりします。
多くの人はですね、あやめのデータセットなどで、
この品種は何だみたいなところをですね、分類するようなことをやったことがあるのではないでしょうか。
それからもう1つが教科学習でございます。
報酬を最大化する試行錯誤と書いていますが、
例えばゲームをAAに勉強させるようなときに、
良いコードだったらご褒美が、悪いコードだったら罰ゲームが、みたいな感じでですね、
報酬を与えていくことによって、
どんどんどんどんAAが自律的に動けるようになりますよ、ということでございます。
それから、正解の一部だけを使う反響詞学習などもあったりして、
実務ではこれらを組み合わせて実施しています。
先ほどあったニューラルネットなんですけども、
これはですね、左の図をまた見ていただければと思うんですが、
丸いノードがですね、線でつながって並んでいます。
これは人間の脳の神経回路、つまりニューロンを真似たものです。
一番左が入力層で、真ん中に隠れ層があって、一番右に出力層があります。
データ左から入って右に抜けていくわけですが、
その際ですね、いろんな線が結ばれていますよね。
このノードとノードをつなぐ線に、重みと呼ばれる数値をどんどんと決めていくと。
この数値を決めるというものが、AIを育てる作業でして、
いわゆるトレーニング、学習というものになります。
この学習を行うにはですね、かなり重たい処理が必要です。
一方で、学習を十分重ねるとですね、
このニューロンの中に情報が保存されていくような形になってですね、
育つと重みで答えを出すことができるわけです。
つまり、最初の段階は、ここからこっちにですね、
どんどん新しい情報をですね、
学習される情報を流しながら、
ここの重みを決めたわけですが、
ある程度重みが決まってしまったらですね、
今まで学習したことのない、
別のデータを与えても、
この重みに従ってちゃんとスログが出る、
といったものになってきます。
この隠れ層をですね、深く、
つまり何層にも隠されたものが、
真相学習と呼ばれるものでございます。
画像、音声、言語の処理に強いということで、
今の生成AIの革新となっています。
AIだとですね、
簡単に勉強できるんじゃないのかと思うかもしれませんが、
このトレーニング、
これは重みという数字をですね、
地道に調整していく作業になるので、
とてもとても勉強は大変なわけでございます。
その真相学習をですね、
さらにお勧めたモデルとして、
トランスフォーマーというものがあります。
これは、系列を並列に扱うことによって、
大量に文章などをですね、
一気に処理できるというものなんですけども、
簡単にですね、
次の言葉を予測しているAIというふうに考えればOKです。
2017年に登場で、
この技術によって、
言葉をしゃべるシャットGPTが出来上がりました。
入力後の並びが与えたときにですね、
セルフアテンションによって、
言葉同士の環境を見て、
その後に情報をまとめ直してですね、
次の5を予測するということをやっています。
ここら辺は動画のですね、
中で、
この動画の中にもありますし、
第3回の方で実際に作ってみて、
詳細を見ていけると思います。
生成AIと普通のAIの違いは何なの?とよく言われますが、
通常のAIというのは、
入力に対して何らかの分類を戻すという場合のタスクがほとんどです。
あるいは、こうなったら異常だよ、
この場合は普通だよというふうな感じですよね。
一方で生成AIというのは、
入力とは全く別なですね、
新しい文章、画像を生成することができます。
つまり、
最もらしい続きというのをですね、
入力に対して作る、
あるいは最もらしいような事例というのを作れるわけです。
言葉におけるAIについてはですね、
次に来る項を一つ選び、
入力して戻すということを繰り返しています。
その文章を扱うモデルが、
ラージランゲージモデル、
大規模言語モデルなわけです。
そのようにして、
AI、
言葉を喋るチャットGPTみたいなものはですね、
概念として出来上がっているわけですが、
昨今はですね、
さらにそこからリーズニング、
推論というものを重ねることによって、
AIがより賢くなっています。
トランスフォーマーがですね、
一回生成するだけでは、
十分に正しい答えが出てきません。
答える前に考える過程を生成したり、
あるいはステップバイステップに分けてですね、
考えたり、
場合によっては繰り返し考えることによって、
AIの回答精度を上げることができる、
というのが発見でございました。
つまり、
次のトークンを読むというところで、
大規模言語モデルがまずあって、
それをもとにですね、
出てきた回答を何回も何回も今度は考えたり、
あるいは分解し考えたりすることによって、
回答の精度を上げている、
というような、
少しレイヤーが違う話というのが、
今出てきたわけですね。
ということで、この動画では、
AIという概念の全体像を説明しました。
AIというのは非常に広い画面で、
人間が知的と考える作業というものがAIなわけですが、
機械学習がその中で現在の種類でございます。
これらはルールで、
一言では言い表せないような問題にむちゃくちゃ強いです。
そして、その学習の正体というところで、
ニューラルネットワーク、ディープラーニングの部分をですね、
説明いたしました。
思いを学習して当てるというものでございます。
そして、そのニューラルネットワークの非常に大規模なものとして、
言語系の生成であるトランスフォーマーがあったりですね、
するというわけでございます。
こうしたですね、
AI技術の全体像というものを、
まず眺めておいた後にですね、
ぜひ、それがどのような形で、
現在の世の中にあるのか、
AIの活用事例みたいな形で、
Google検索したり、
AIに聞いてみると出てくると思いますから、
ぜひ確認してみてください。
それでは、本動画のご視聴ありがとうございました。